ça fait quand même non je suis alors
vous avez découvert le bouddhisme auprès
d'une personne proche qui lutter contre
une maladie en récitant une phrase un
mantra est ce que c'est une amie orgue
et kyo n'hésitait pas seulement ça
c'était une pratique beaucoup plus
approfondie du collège alors c'est le
son qui est produit par la répétition de
cette phrase à une fonction sur le sur
le cerveau c'est vrai mais c'est parce
que c'est se concentrer en fait sur un
mantra capter son attention et ça permet
de 200 par là dedans de faire le vide en
fait et en 80 rencontres profond parce
qu'on se pose et l'esprit arrêtent de
travailler de travailler tout le temps
les gens sous vide
non justement on est plein mais ne soit
pas de l'extérieur voilà alors j'ai fait
un livre qui s'appelle trouver le chemin
chez michel lafon
vous n'êtes pas venu en parler ici non
parce que j'en ai parlé chez fogiel on
m'a dit tu es fort gérard bitton et
comme les dates
je
non c'est un problème de bâton plus donc
on pouvait mais ce que j'étais en
tournée donc c'est un peu y avait de
bonnes choses qui peut jamais l'été
parce que je les lui chez bouquins et ça
vachement bien quand on aurait dit des
choses pour me dope le soleil de cette
barre oui mais en tout cas je sais qu'il
a fait beaucoup de bien beaucoup de gens
et comme il est c'est fait dans ce sens
est alors justement dans ce bouquin vous
racontez vous avez un cancer à l'âge de
22 ans qui nous empêcher de devenir mère
à jamais vous expliquez assez
naturellement d'ailleurs que bon bah
voilà c'était presque un mal pour un
bien
vous avez bien promues t1 toute épreuve
en fait et nous appartient de la
transformer de la dépasser et moi c'est
ce que j'ai eu je crois vraiment le
bonheur de faire vous avez profité bon
sur un plan disons or couple un oui
voilà oui nivea oui oui je pense que
avoir un enfant change change tout dans
une ville et un sens de responsabilité
qui est c'est une scéne parce que je
pense qu'on a commencé à prendre la peur
de tout aussi aux sénateurs pour eux je
suis encore se montre que plus attention
à ce qu'on fait alors que moi je c'est
vrai que j'ai je n'ai peur de rien
finalement parce que je n'ai pas peur
pour lui vous avez bien profité on va
pas s'appesantir là dessus c'est pas le
style de l'émission j'ai profité de la
vie voilà dj et et voilà oui c'était
maîtresse de la ville oui voilà on est
désolé d'avoir profité
parce que naissait pas les blocs en même
temps et alors non sérieusement au delà
de ça il n'ya l'humanitaire aussi
sérieux vous occuper beaucoup d'enfants
tibétain avec une association qui
s'appelle graines d'avenir pour
préserver la culture de ces enfants qui
ont été obligés souvent de quitter leur
pays même pour rester tibétains ils sont
obligés de s'expatrier sont obligés de
traverser l'école himalayens pour
rejoindre l'inde ou en fête des sports à
tibetan est établi et maintient la
culture tibétaine impacte donc ses
enfants pour pouvoir être éduqués dans
leur culture pour pouvoir continuer à
apprendre apprendre leur langue en fait
à être élevés dans le dans leur langue
maternelle et dans leur culture sont
obligés de s'exiler en inde
ça s'arrange pas se taper moi je me
souviens j'avais 10 ans je voyais aux
actualités au cinéma noir et blanc le
départ du dalaï lama qui fuyaient le
tibet devant l'avancée des troupes
chinoises tard
et voilà il ya 50 ans et aujourd'hui
c'est toujours pas réglé c'est pourquoi
est ce que le monde a mis si longtemps
pour regarder ce peuple et pour se
rendre compte que en plus c'est vraiment
une culture c'est au-delà c'est en plus
un peuple il ya aussi une culture c'est
qui est une richesse planétaire et dont
on n'est pas conscient c'est une culture
extraordinaire c'est magnifique et ça on
ne le dit pas bon c'est vrai que quand
je pense j'ai créé cette association
c'est vrai que ces humanitaires mais
c'est au delà
j'ai l'impression de faire en même temps
un devoir d'être humains dans l'air de
citoyens du monde
devoir de mémoire tous les pays font du
business avec la chine et la chine
n'aime pas du tout qu'on lui parle du
tibet pas du tout d'après que ce que
j'ai entendu un des plus jeunes
prisonniers politiques au monde
c'est la dame s'est scellé comme ce type
est un c'était un matin c'était un
tibétain qui a été enlevée à l'âge de
sept ans et qui n'ont jamais revu et le
panchen lama est le seul qui puisse se
reconnaître en fait le dalaï lama le
prochain dalaï lama donc c'est
dramatique parce qu'ils ont mis leur
punch et cela m'a donc ça veut dire que
le prochain dalaï lama en fête sera
reconnu par les chinois 1
donc c'est tout souvent la traite en
train de partir en ce qui est fascinant
c'est comment une puissance aussi grande
a peur d'un pays comme le tibet pour
quelles raisons pour quelles raisons
géopolitiques qui veulent avoir le tibet
dans leur zone d'influencé puis surtout
parce que ça donne le la
et si nos canaris toit et se ferme quand
c'est chez michel pour madame est servie
je suis en
au trouver le chemin théo 6 et michel
lafon mesdames messieurs
à